مع دخول قرار فرض الحد الاقصى لسعر النفط
الروسي المنقول بحرا حيز التنفيذ موسكو
اعلنت رفضها القرار وتجهيز رد عليه الكريم
لن اعتبر ان الخطوه ستزعزع استقرار سوق
الطاقه العالميه وستؤثر على الاوروبيين
انفسهم ثاني اكبر مصدر للنفط في العالم
روسيا قالت انها لن تقبل السقف السعريه
ولن تبيع النفط المسعر به حتى لو اضطرت
الى خفض الانتاج موسكو اكدت ان القرار لن
تكون له تداعيه على الهجوم الروسي في
اوكرانيا
دول مجموعه السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي
واستراليا بدا التطبيق السقف السحري
المحدد عند 60 دولار اجراء يسمح بشحن
النفط الروسي الى دول اخرى باستخدام
ناقلات لمجموعه السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي
وشركات التامين ومؤسسه الائتمان وذلك فقط
اذا تم شراء الشحنه بالسقف السعريه المحدد
او اقل
وباعتبار ان شركات الشحن والتامين الكبرى
في العالم في دول المجموعه سيصعب على
موسكو ان تبيع نفطها بسعر اعلى بيع النفط
والغاز الى اوروبا
الاجنبيه لروسيا منذ اكتشافه ما في
مستنقعات سيبيريا في العقود التي تلد
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
العربي العربيه